[Music]
most people think about lions in Africa
but very few people know that they
actually exist in India - it looks not
very different from the African lion it
is however a bit smaller
it does have floppy skin on the stomach
that looks different
also they live in in smaller groups
because they live in the forest the prey
they hunt is not as big as the buffalos
in Africa it's mostly deers or antelopes
the Asiatic Lion was the lion that
people would use in the Coliseum the
Romans would use it to fight the
gladiators there used to be a lot of
lines in Asia and Europe actually the
numbers were decimated the girl forest
is the last pocket of safety for the
Lions
in many ways the Asiatic lions are doing
better than their counterparts in Africa
they are very well protected in the girl
forest so while the numbers of African
line are going down the numbers of
Asiatic lions are still growing
the only problem is that the girl forest
is getting too small for them so right
now you actually have lines entering
into cities small villages in Gujarat it
is really nice to think about that there
is actually a lion population somewhere
in the world where numbers are growing
[Music]
you